okay. Uh, if we're not careful, the United
States as soon going to be at war with Iran,
this is of course the same Iran that has stuck
tip every provision of the Iran nuclear deal
until of course, Donald Trump decided to avoid
that deal unilaterally. And I told you earlier
this week that Donald Trump is adding sanctions
to Iran. Iran has done what any rational actor
would do in that situation, which is they
said, well, listen, we didn't break the deal.
We stuck to the conditions of the deal. If
you are unilaterally voiding the deal and
you are adding sanctions to us, then we'll
go back to researching and developing nuclear
technology, which could be used for weapons.
And I think it's important for me to restate
in case there are any bad faith actors out
there waiting to pounce on me. I don't want
Iran to develop nuclear weapons. I don't want
to run to have nuclear weapons. I have not
been a someone who has claimed ever.
I would argue that the Iranian, um, uh, forces
of power are good faith actors I have not
said or done or nor do I want any of those
things. But this is obviously the logical
decision if you are in neurons position as
a result of Donald Trump's decisions. And
now Donald Trump is starting to scale up hostilities
and Donald Trump is trying to end all arrange
Ian oil, steel and copper exports. Iran is
now heading closer and closer towards an economic
crisis. And now the pre war propaganda starts.
And I don't know what's true and what isn't.
To be perfectly honest with you, United States
officials are now claiming that Iran is preparing
military strikes against the United States
in the Middle East. They say that the um,
uh, that Iran is getting ready for a attacking
commercial and military ships in the Persian
Gulf. Could it be true? Sure. Absolutely.
Is it actually true?
I don't know. United States has a long history
of having leaders that lie to us about so
called imminent threats to create military
engagements for what they perceive to be political
benefit. A U s intelligence also seems to
be making the assessment that Iran is actions
might be to deliberately goad Trump in to
taking actions since those actions could be
a politically problematic for Donald Trump.
And for the United States given are almost
constant disastrous involvement in the region
for decades at this point in time. And there's
the risk that that could be bad for Donald
Trump politically, although at the same time
it could be good for Trump politically to
get involved in a with Iran. Um, you may have
heard over the weekend that there were four
attacks on oil tankers in the Persian Gulf.
They have not as of yet been blamed on Iran.
It's under investigation according to our
secretary of state.
And the Trump administration has very quickly
shifted into reviewing military plans for
Iran, which are starting to smell like and
starting to look like and starting to sound
like the pre Iraq war era. And the lead up
that eventually got us thinking it was about
130,000 troops in Iraq. And in fact the very
similar number of plan being presented to
Donald Trump, which would move 120,000 American
troops to the Middle East if Iran attacks
American soldiers or ramps up nuclear development
or does the other things that the Trump administration
claims Iran is thinking about doing or preparing
to do. We heard from Trump national security
adviser, John Bolton, who's right in there
with this plan of going into Iran and he has
been in Iran War Hawk for a long time and
in fact he wanted to go into Iran when he
worked for George W. Bush and he was not able
to convince George W. Bush to do it.
We thought maybe his presence, his national
security advisor would give them another shot
and it seems that we're closer than we have
been at any other point during the Trump presidency
to John Bolton. Getting that opportunity and
we're talking about a serious engagement here.
Okay, 120,000 troops. That's not a 1500 troop
peacekeeping or training mission. This is
a large scale operation that has been presented
to Trump. There are articles which are using
the term drifting. We're drifting towards
war with Iran. That's not the right imagery.
Trump has been pushing us towards war with
Iran ever since. He decided to bail on the
Iran nuclear deal without Iran having done
anything to deserve that. And the hilarious
thing is that now Trump administration officials
have started to pay lip service to things
like, you know, we would prefer a diplomatic
solution with Iran, but we can't take anything
off the table.
It would be bad strategy to take military
action off the table. We had a diplomatic
solution. It was the Iran nuclear deal, which
diplomat Barack Obama put in place. And Donald
Trump has unilaterally voided without good
cause. And so when the newspapers cover this,
including the Washington Post and the New
York Times who have done very good investigative
work over the last several years, the newspapers
covering this need to stop playing coy with
the language drifting towards war is very
passive language in a way. Considering, uh,
what a plan might look like. The United States
is that the party that is causing this, not
the party reacting to what Iran is doing,
everything Iran has done. And I am no defender
of Iran by any means. I've been critical of
the regime there. What Iran is doing is the
obvious reaction to what the Trump administration
has done. This is all on us and specifically
on the Trump administration because of his
actions and the Washington Post and the New
York Times should just say in their op eds
that Trump is pushing us towards war.
Not that there is this passive sort of floating
in the ocean drift in that direction. No more
pussy footing. Let's actually tell it like
it is because that's what's going on and it's
really bad.